whoa whoa whoa what's going on he's like
oh you know I was like what are we doing
okay this is all time obviously y'all
y'all never kissed a girl she has I have
it you have you know this my idea yes
you're not gonna get the story for the
vlog good morning sweetie what are we
doing today hey we're on our way to fish
market Oh super early super cool just
met up with the risk while eating an
orange that Joe gave me last night which
cost like there's a million dollars it's
really expensive
hey are you excited to eat the orange
and the most best freshest sushi that
you've ever had in your entire life ever
all down so fish market means freshest
fish in the world
we getting first pick today oh look a
dark circles holy crap
I want to sleep really late last night
Gina made me a back and she really a bad
and I just fell asleep in a tub
yeah the high price to pay for a for the
high life of traveling and for me it's
these double chins coming in eating so
much okay there she comes in number two
look Sheila says you can do the robot
it's just a book test only one movie I
want to be surprised
Jack miss you were really good at
dancing oh let's do it all right
one for the variety pack today got the
tofu stuff that fat stuff and I got a
early morning so I decided to get an egg
one rice wait what you're getting so
much food we're about to go key oh
you're right I'm gonna put this one back
I sure you got him what you got would
you get both it was like losing like I
mean you already ate it man I'm not
gonna use this cliff head oh there's no
proof of what you got you're just
chewing on garbage right now for all I
know this is where we're meeting up with
the fish guy this is like we should have
gone to Fuji today in the fish market
yesterday
what is this isn't Mount Fuji weather
for sure the Buddhist guys don't like us
American Abbey
just kidding
what we're gonna swim the clunkers okay
you go together Gina day you look too
close to my girlfriend you know they're
too close to my girlfriend what fish
ladies they're gonna take us to eat some
sushi hi my name is Casey and I didn't
aguirre boys
you toasting all right we're going
separate ways because we were rolling 17
deep and we can all scroll through their
fish market so we've broken up into four
groups I am stuck with Michael roll boys
then you give your boys that we are the
nigiri boys whoo this is a
lost-and-found for today this lets you
have a lot so far a wallet it's a
scallops that is crazy if you'll return
scallops
my god you let me hold it
we are in the fish market finally and
it's hectic as hell
oh my goodness don't know what that was
cool called tamagoyaki come on go means
a salsa news at the topping of the sushi
we Japanese leaders of a nut bread class
just have a tomorrow and I have to say
with the best of our ever ahead I don't
even normally like it so I serve cold
it's kind of hard when actual Mago was
fluffy and warm and it was not too sweet
oh my god
all right so apparently Michelin star
restaurants come here to pick their fish
fat means this place is really really
good quality and it's really quiet for
some reason in here so now with curry
savvy roots wasabi root I feel like we
need to walk around with one big tag on
it says send me my said we're just
forever send me my sending which means
excuse me you're sorry because we're
getting in the way of everyone wanted
heart-shaped water a white Harbor yeah
that's regular strawberry I like
strawberry Michelin star restaurants
also get all their produce from this
area and we're just trying this is all
fruit I mean this warehouse goes for
days this is the whole fruit oh my
goodness the I mean they're auctioning
the finest melons right now and their
food game on point over here man they're
auctioning melons America it's like
cricket
you laugh at you like all going to melon
heart
all those old guys up there they're all
like MasterChef or something there's
someone powerful those are some
expensive ass balance that is it the
auction is over
they bow in and bow out we are now
entering the fish market this will be
vol been waiting for
oh my gosh
oh my goodness look at that that's tag
must cost a fortune right there 400,000
yen Floria 400,000 yen
he said he wakes at 3 o clock every
morning that is some dedication dude
that guy is the most never seen
to see it thank you such a huge
my tour groups leaving I gotta go I love
you this is like a foodies ultimate
experience right here this is a better
than Disneyland Ben for Isaac is ever
Isaac's temporizing yeah Jojo and Jess
actually opted not to come here today
this jess is feeling tired and so they
they took Heinz again for the day and
they're babysitting him so this is which
is great because I think you know I
think would have been ran over somehow
by down by one of those cards are flying
around but this is amazing legend has it
is that if you eat eel you get samurai
strength we shall deal today this is the
very very first Yoshinoya ever and it
all started right here doesn't even have
a lick of English on it first Yoshinoya
open in 1895 it's been here for
don't argue man here over here over
hundreds every legend did it I just had
yeah was it good I was really conflicted
because you know back mistake it's
really you know we just need them pop
your own
that's actually an edible it's like you
can eat well no one stopped me from
eating it back in the states you rest
upper my hand I'm about to eat it I was
I'm eating an insect in my life here we
go
here choose grasshoppers are amazing
we're gonna try
so fried fish gates
is pretty good oh yeah barrel they're
real good very gingery hi ginger
all right so this is some sort of clam
and some other clam and some other town
all torched and stood on the shell of a
clam clam on clam on clam on clam that
was it that was the hostel that's like
the best thing had so far in a Tokyo
actually I think it beats the sushi why
dance because I've never had it before
that makes it ten times better when you
find something delicious for the first
time oh my god I want enough okay I
think that dish would have done really
well with some beer we're trying to
remake that one day at home maybe a
recipe video I don't know I think it was
sucky soy sauce and blowtorches I think
five mice listen blowtorches to make
that this is some green tea to give you
boys Oh Gary boys Cheers
oh my god that is amazing so right now
we're about to heat this uni but inside
it's like in the bud I've never had this
before steaming so everybody can bite at
this Unni but I guess there we go
that was good but I didn't have a lot of
clean up though around cute why number
206 butter so butter you what really
pretty much myself yeah I do want to try
some oh my goodness you're right
they made a Winnie inch of butter here
it's a buttered roll between the bun has
like a very sweet aromatic flavor and
then those Mooney is kind of salty so
it's a very good takeaway do these
oysters are oh you guys look I look how
big this thing is
it's bigger than our hands oh my god
okay boy giddy boys Cheers
Oh
is the one is the one as well here
coffee so hard
boy stur time
got a drinkin oh my god I've had my life
Matt oh my god
bring on the beard now that was probably
the sweetest moisture I've ever had in
my life
boy stirs in the states have this funky
taste to I mean I like it anyways I eat
it regardless but goddamn that water was
clean tasting all right we had this
earlier this is tamago he's making it
for us I really owe Larry
genius at home and I
it's hard to make at home game is very
hard I'm burning yeah Oh make it make it
to the shape my egg is so malleable you
do like a lot of stuff with eggs oh look
at that
look at that she's traditional sake coke
oh oh I didn't know sake comes to school
here shot five times much really good
cedar tree before half or you can choose
how this boy oh that's really full yeah
you guys cigarette
cheers Cheers no that was really smooth
it tastes almost like water but then
it's like it was a sweetness nice no you
better stop gaily and dudes cutting up
some Toro and ever examples one little
bite is 700 yes do you see it over there
it was through a chunk of
that weekend Toro is fatty tuna that's
regular tuna it's all red that's pink
because the fat is why and it makes it
look a lot lighter it is probably the
best buy the sushi in the world Shawn
Michaels ass
how many you on my hands today that's
the traditional way we were just
instructed to dip sushi fish side or
else the rice will break so what are we
about to do now like my whole life I
personally would never ever I thought we
wanted a touch it out
here this creeper over here you missing
Muriel
clearly this array meets all these
Poonam no we're still love you but I
have all of you took me five seconds to
think of that x-ray with the salty a say
you need to point it out like so what
are we doing we're hugging no this
handing out a couple times
third wheel where are we this place is
crazy this is not what I expected
you hate at me you wait at me
I think I found the one creature that
has bigger eyes than you that guy
all right we are now on a way to each
year on ramen because we heard that you
cheer on ramen is [ __ ] bomb we posted
a picture of some other ramen and you
guys are telling us that we should go to
ichiraku ramen so I want to say you
cheer out Robin one more time
Pete you're on ramen and Breschel you
station now crossing we valiant station
booyah
in the nighttime and what's up Dan what
are you doing in Japan Clara what are we
doing in Japan triangle beat you into
both it both of you guys I think it's
always damn near impossible for you guys
to do that cool ramen in the last three
hours it's rush hour time
on a weekday we're doing it across the
ocean or how hard to get a great photo
op did she ride
wait a Qunari Oh itchy were on there did
you run ramen so this place
apparently sections you off it's your
own little cubicle and you eat ramen I'm
pretty excited to actually this is it
this is an experience right here oh we
can we all we can see each other right
oh we're eating together now take down
the Berlin Wall take it yeah sorry
smack it in the face see I can read this
actually that's 11 12 13 14 13
it looks just like Chinese Chinese oh
[ __ ] so we get a cup and then we get our
own water whenever we want no need to
bother with the waiter my server has no
face that's okay we go we don't can't be
in there I don't know ask her we got her
pants let's do a toast Cheers
should we wait we tapped glasses already
just hit the phone you were said as you
know Michael said you actually come back
here tomorrow considering the number two
limited a days that we haven't talked to
you all right I mean this good that's
what social media means now the memory
is more important than the actual
experience of the good food that's
sitting in front of you hi
always Oh Cho ha is it better than a cup
of noodles okay first thing I like doing
s the broth
that is flavor
give me the stylus review this is really
good we're getting [ __ ] up tonight
yeah Cheers
ninja beer
what is that typical Asian what is that